kanye west is debuting a bold new look
[Music]
here's the 44 year old rapper donning a
green mask with a balenciaga jacket
black jeans and black boots seems like
kanye was trying to keep a low profile
while being escorted through an airport
in venice italy with the mask that
covered his entire head the musician was
in italy attending and performing at a
very lavish wedding in fact it's the
same nuptials beyonce and jay-z were
also at drummer questlove attended the
event too and shared a clip of kanye's
performance wearing yet again a face
covering but this one a little different
that's kanye in the black mask
[Music]
fellow rapper bori also posted a photo
with kanye at the wedding donning a
similar mask and revealed in the caption
that he was styled by the rapper and
balenciaga underneath those many looks
the wrap and fashion mogul's new haircut
on monday kanye revealed his latest
hairdo on instagram the image features
shaved portions of his head along with
an homage to one of his kids that's a
necklace with the word saint on it the
name of his five-year-old son he shares
with kim kardashian kanye captioned the
photo with a japanese yen symbol which
many fans think could be a nod to his
new name yay et has learned that kanye's
request to legally change his name to
yay has officially been granted by the
los angeles courts it's extremely
important to me yey isn't only the
rapper's name it's also a word very
familiar to his work in 2018 kanye
released his eighth studio album of the
same name and in that same year kanye
explained in an interview with radio
host big boy why the word is so
important to him i believe yay is the
most commonly used word in the bible and
in the bible it means you
so it's i'm you i'm us
it's us it went from being kanye which
means the only one to just yay just
being a reflection of our good our bad
our confused everything that i'm just
more of a reflection of who we are